สวัสดีค่ะครูนิกสวัสดีครับครูหญิงสวัสดี
นักเรียนทุกคนด้วยนะครับสวัสดีค่ะนัก
เรียนอ่าเดี๋ยวเรามาเขียนวันที่กันนะคะ
ครับครูนิคะวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วัน
พฤหัสบครับวันพฤหัสที่เท่าไหร่คะวันพฤหัส
ที่ 3 ครับเดือนอะไรคะ
เดือน
พฤศจิกายนครับปีพ.ศอะไร
คะปีพ.ศ
25  6  5 ปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
20  22 ครับค่ะตอนนี้ที่บ้านครูนิกกี่
โมงแล้วคะตอนนี้นะครับที่บ้านครูนิกตอน
นี้ครูนิกกำลัง
เทน้ำอ๋อนึกว่าครูนี้กำลังดูเวลาอยู่เอ๊ะ
กี่โมงกำลังเทชงนี้คอแห้งเอ่อตอนนี้ครับ
เวลา
20:12 น
อ่า
20:12 นนะคะก็กลางคืนเนาะบ้านคุณนี้ก็
เป็นเวลากลางคืนแล้วนะคะแล้วที่ไทยล่ะ
ครับที่ไทยตอนนี้อ่า
8 นค่ะ 12 นที่ไทยเนี่ยเป็นตอนกลางวัน
เนาะเป็นตอนเช้านะคะแล้วก็เป็นวันที่ 4
ด้วยนะคะวันศุกร์
แล้วอืนะวันนี้ของครูนิกแล้วก็วันนี้ของ
ครูหญิงไม่เหมือนกันนะคะนักเรียนเพราะว่า
เราอยู่กันคนเราอยู่กันไกลมากๆเราอยู่ไกล
กันมากๆครับใช่ๆอื
ก็แล้วไม่รู้เมื่อกี้ครูครูหญิงสังเกต
หรือเปล่าเวลาครูนิกอ่ะคุณนี้ก็จะนับ
อันเนี้ยคือ 1 อืเออ
เหมือนผู้หญิงเนี่ยนิ้วก้อยไง 1  2  3  4
5 อ 1  2  3  1  2
3 ไม่ได้อ่ะได้ 4 ไม่ได้แล้วอ่ะ 4  5
นี่ทำได้ยังไง
อ่ะอืผู้หญิงไม่ได้เลยค่ะข้างซ้ายก็ไม่
ได้ข้างขวาก็ไม่ได้อืคือคุณนิกอ่ะทำแบบ
นั้นเพราะว่าตอนคือคุณนิกเคยเรียนที่
ฝรั่งเศสแล้วอันเนี้ยในยุโรปเนี่ยเขาจะทำ
อย่างเงี้ยคือ 1
อืแต่คนไทยบางไทยบางทีจะทำแบบเยคือ 6 ค่ะ
แต่ของเค้าคือถ้า 6 ก็จะอย่างงี้
อื
ใช่แต่นี้คือ 1 ใช่ 1 คุณนี้ก็เลยชินเหรอ
คะมันก็ก็ชินแต่ตอนนี้คือมันชินแล้วบาง
ครั้งก็ทำสลับเหมือนกับที่ไทยเบางทีก็
หนึ่งแบบนี้บางทีก็1ึแบบนี้ใช่อืก็เคยเคย
ตอนแรกเนี่ยที่ไปที่ไปที่ฝรั่งเศสใหม่ๆ
คุณนิกทำอย่างี้ข้ 1 อืเคก็งง
อะไรเลขอะไรอหรอคือแค่แบบอย่างงี้เา้าก็
เลยแบบแล้วคูนิกเป็นยังไงอ่ะตอนนั้นเวลา
ทุกคนมองว่านิกทำอะไรอันนี้คืออะไรก็ตอน
นั้นก็หน้าแตกนิดนึงเพราะว่าคือเมื่อก่อน
เด็กๆนะเป็นคนขี้อายทำอะไรแล้วกลัวขาย
หน้าเออกลัวขายก็คือเหมือนกับถ้าเกิดทำ
อะไรแล้วคนเห็นแล้วมันไม่ใช่หรือมัน
เค้าตลกอย่างเงี้ยแล้วพอเค้าหัวเราะให้
เราแบบทำอะไรแบบนั้นเราก็จะอแตกขายหน้า
แบบนั้นใช่อเหมือนเวลาที่เราแบบว่าเราไป
ที่ที่เราไม่เคยไปแล้วเราไม่รู้ว่าคนที่
นี่เอ๊ะเค้าทำยังไงแต่เราไม่รู้อ่ะใช่เรา
ก็ทำแบบของเราแล้วทุกคนก็แบบดูผู้ชายคน
นั้นดิเคทำอะไรอ่ะ
ที่หน้าอือายอ่ะทำไมเราไม่รู้ใช่อันนี้
คิดว่าทุกคนเป็นเหมือนกันนะครูครับใช่ก็
เป็นเหมือนกันแต่พออืมคิดว่าตอนนี้ก็คือ
ตอนเนี้ยไม่ค่อยเท่าไหร่ะไม่ไม่ค่อยกลัว
แล้วถ้าทำอะไรผิดก็เออทุกคนก็ผิดได้หมด
แต่เมื่อก่อนอย่าเงี้ยพอตอนเด็กๆแบบวย
รุ่นอืมจะต้องมีความมั่นใจอายุ 15  16  17
อย่างเงี้ใช่มใช่ใช่ยิ่งตอนมหาเรียน
มหาวิทยาลัยแบบเนี้ยกับเพื่อนเยอะๆเนี่ย
จะต้องมีความมั่นใจมากๆอืแล้วคค่ะอ๋อไม่
คือคือเหมือนกับว่าตอนนั้นเพราะว่าที่ครู
นิกเรียนจะมีด้วยที่คณะที่ครูนิกเรียน
ด้วยมันก็จะมีคนที่เค้ามีความมั่นใจสูง
กันเยอะอ่าเแบบว่าฉันทำได้นะนะใครไม่ได้อ
เออแล้วครูนิกบอกว่าครูนิกเนี่ยเวลาทำ
อะไรใช่มั้ยแล้วก็เด็กๆเนี่ยเป็นคนขี้อาย
ไม่อยากหน้าแตกหรือว่าไม่อยากแบบทำอะไร
แล้วขายหน้าอืถ้างั้นเนี่ยมันก็อาจจะต้อง
มีเหตุการณ์อะไรหรือเปล่าคะที่ครูนิกเคย
ทำแล้วขายหน้าแล้วครูนิกเนี่ยไม่ลืมอ่ะ
ยังจำได้จนถึงทุกวันนี้มีมยมีมีมีแน่นอน
อันนี้เนี่ยที่จำได้เลยถึงทุกวันเนี้ยคือ
เป็นเรื่องขายหน้าตอนที่คุณนิกมาที่
อเมริกาครั้งแรก
หึนานหรือยังคะครูนิกกี่ปีแล้วเอ่อ 15 ปี
ที่แล้วโห 15 ปีที่แล้วก็ประมาณ 2007
มั้ยใช่ครับใช่ 2  7 ใช่เกิดอะไรขึ้น
คะเกิดอะไรขึ้นคืออันนี้เนี่ยครูนิกอยู่
ในลิฟต์ค่ะอยู่ในลิฟต์กำลังจะลงลิฟต์ไปรอ
เพื่อนเพราะว่าจะไปข้างนอกกับเพื่อนแล้ว
ทีนี้
คุณนี้ิก็อยู่ในลิฟต์แล้วตอนนั้นน่ะคนนี้
ก็ปวดท้องไม่จงว่าปวดท้องหรอกครับแต่
เหมือนกับรู้สึกว่าในท้อง้องคุณนนมันมีลม
อ๋อมีแก๊สเยอะมันแบบอืปุ๊งๆปุงๆน่าจะต้อง
มาะแต่คนนี้บบไม่เป็นไรลงลิฟเนี่ยแป๊บ
เดียวแล้วก็อั้นเอาไว้ก่อนก็คือถ้ามันจะ
ออกว่าอย่าเพิ่งเก็บไว้
ก่อนแล้วตอนที่ลงมาเนี่ยมันมีคนเข้ามา
เรื่อยๆเรื่อยๆคุณนิก็คิดว่าทำไมมันคนกด
ทุกชั้นเลยหิกำลังจะบอกเลยว่าลิฟจอดทุก
ชั้นหรือเปล่าคุณนิกอยู่ชั้น 10 อ่ะชั้น 9
ก็จอดชั้น 8 ก็จอดชั้น 7 ชั้น 6 กว่าจะ
ถึงชั้น 1 แล้วลิฟจอด 1 ชั้นเนี่ยมันใช้
เวลาอยู่นะใช่ใช่ก็นั่นแหละคุณนี้ก็คิดใน
หัวว่าโอ้ยทำไมมันช้า
จังนี้โอ๊ยทำไงดีไม่เป็นไรแป๊บนึงแปบบนึง
ใกล้แล้วแล้วพอถึงชั้นล่างเนี่ยชั้นที่
คครูนิกจะลงคูนิโอเคถึงซะทีประตูเปิดครู
นิกก็เดินออกไปครูนิกอ่ะยังไม่พ้นประตูนะ
แล้วมันอั้นไม่ได้แล้วไม่ไหวแล้วใช่มยมัน
เก็บมาตั้งแต่แบบกชั้นน่ะที่จอดเออมันก็
เลยต้องออกมาคุณนิกะก็ตดใน
ลิฟตคือสมมุติว่าอันนี้เป็นประตูลิฟต์นะ
คะประตูลิฟตเนี่ยเปิดแล้วกูนิเนี่ยกำลัง
เดินเดินเดๆๆจะพ้นแล้วนะใช่จะพ้นแล้วแต่
ว่าไม่ไม่แล้วก็คือมันก็
ปุ๋งออก
ไปมีเสียงมั้ยคะะเสียงมีเสียง
มีเดี๋ยวนะคุณนี้กำลังดูกมได้ๆไม่มีโฟกัส
โอเคโเอ่ะมี
เสียง
มีกลิ่นมั้ยครูนิกอ่ะคิดว่ามีกลิ่นเพราะ
ในลิฟอ่ะมีคน
ออพอครูนิกเดินออกมามันตดไปแล้ว
ไงแล้วสิ่งที่คุณนิกได้ยินเนี่ยคือคนใน
ลิฟบอกว่าโอ๊ยอะไรนี่
เนี่ยใช่รู้มั้ยคะว่าเป็นครูนิกรู้เพราะ
ว่าก็ครูนิกออกไปแล้วเสียงมันมาตามของ
คครูนิกไงแล้วคือคครูนิกก็ไม่ได้ไม่กล้า
เพราะคครูนิกก็ขายหน้าไม่กล้าเข้าไปดูใน
ลิฟตเพราะพอดว่าโอ๊ยอะไรเนี่ยประตูมันก็
ปิดเออเพราะว่าถ้าครูดิ๊กหันไปก็คือแบบ
ตอนเนี้ยเพราะว่าตอนพอมันมีเสียงปุ๊งออก
มาหน้าคครูนิก็ก็คือแบบคุนี้อยากจะมุดใช่
ก็คือหน้าขายหน้าแล้วอ่ะแบบไม่อยากเจอคน
เออก็แล้วพอลงไปเนี่ยครูนิกก็คิดว่าจะเจอ
เพื่อนเพื่อนครูนิกยังไม่มา
อ๋อคุณนก็อ้าวแล้วยังไงดีถ้าจะกดลิฟกลับ
ไปที่ห้องแล้วรอให้เพื่อนบอกว่ามาแล้ว
แล้วถ้าจะเจอคนที่อยู่ในลิฟต์ด้วยกัน
เมื่อกี้ล่ะเาอาจจะตีเราก็ได้แต่ว่าคุณนิ
กล้าเอาหน้าไปเจอเค้าเหรอคะไม่ไม่ไงก็ขาย
หน้าแล้วหน้ามันไปแล้วไม่ไม่อยากเจอ
ใช่แล้วคุณนี้อาจจะยืนรออยู่แล้วเขาก็ออก
มาจากลิฟต์พอดีแบบเอาจจะขึ้นไปแล้วก็ลงมา
ก็ไม่รู้เนาะแล้วก็บอกนี่ไงคนนเคนเแหละ
ที่มันเมื่อ
กี้เอาจริงนะอันนี้คือแบบว่าแบบขายหน้า
มากคือแบบอายมากไม่ไหวนะคะแล้วทุกคนรู้
ด้วยว่าเรามีคนตดใน
ลิฟต์แล้วก็อ่าพอพูดถึงนะคุณนิก็นึกได้
อีกเรื่องนึงเกี่ยวกับตดเหมือนกันมันก็มี
อีกครั้งนึงเกี่ยวกับตดนัไม่รู้คุณนิกก
คิดว่าต้องไปหาหมอะไปบอกว่าคุณคุณหมอครับ
ช่วยด้วยเนี่ยในท้องมันมีแก๊สเยอะมากๆเออ
ผมเก็บไม่ไหว
ครับอีกเรื่องนึงคือคุณนิกะเคยตดในวัด
หาในในโบกในอุโบสถอ่ะ
อื
แบบคือโบสถเนี่ยคุณนี้คะมันมันปิด 100%
เลย
นะคิดว่าเดี๋ยวคุณหญิงต้องเปิดรูปให้นัก
เรียนเข้าใจโบสถ์ก่อนนะคะะคุณคุณครับเอ้ย
มันต้องเป็นโบสถ์โบสถ์ของเราเนาะ
อือืเพราะว่าโบสถ์บางครั้งมันอาจจะคิดถึง
ของอ่าศาสนาคริสตครับใช่มันก็แบบนี้ได้
เนาะจรินี้ก็ไม่ได้เห็นนะเดี๋ยวคครูนิก
จะมีรูปให้ดูครูนิกเดี๋ยวเจอรูปเดี๋ยวคุณ
นิกจะแชร์หน้าจอให้นะ
ครับคือเหมือนก็เป็นอุโบสกแบบนี้ใช่อืใช่
นักเรียนเห็นมั้ยส่วนใหญ่เนี่ยหน้าต่างนะ
คะหน้าต่างเนี่ยเค้าก็จะปิดเไม่เปเค้าจะ
เปิดแค่แค่ประตูนี้เท่านั้นน่ะอันเนี้ย
คือหน้าต่างนะคะหน้าต่างเนี่ยปิดปิดประตู
ที่มันเข้า
ออกูนิไปตดในโบสถ์เหรอคะเหตุการณ์มันเป็น
ยังไงเรื่องมันเป็นยังไงคะเหตุการณ์มัน
เกิดขึ้นเพราะว่าคืออันนี้เนี่ยเป็นตอน
เรียนม 5 ค่ะจำได้ว่าม
5 อายุประมาณ 17 เนาะช่วงอุ้ยวัยรุ่น
ด้วยนะครูนิก
ไง
คือตอนนั้นเนี่ยของโรงเรียนครูนิกเนี่ย
ถ้าม 5 เาจะให้ไปเาจะให้ม 5 ทุกห้องไปนอน
ที่วัด 3  3 วันอืเหมือนกับไปค้างเหมือน
เป็นค่ายธรรมะก็คือต้องไปนอนที่วัดแล้วใน
แต่ละวันเก็จะมีกิจกรรมให้ทำว่าโอเคนะจะ
เรียนเกี่ยวกับ
พุทธศาสนาใช่นั่ง
สมาธิสวดมนต์แบบนี้นะโมตัสสะใช่
ก็เกิดขึ้นตอนที่ทำกิจกรรมเนี่ยแหละก็คือ
อยู่ในโบสถ์อยู่ในอุโบสถแล้วก็ทำกิจกรรม
เหมือนกับเป็นการอ่านธรรมะอก็อ่าน่านไป
แล้วจะต้อง
เอ่อไหว้พระค่ะใช่ก็คือเวลาอยู่วัดเรา
ไหว้พระเราก็ต้องนั่งนั่งแล้วก็เหมือนกับ
ยกไหว้แบบเนี้ยครับที่คนไทยก็จะบอกเหมือน
กับอ่าอัญชลีวันทาอภิวาทแบบนี้ออก็เหมือน
แบบ 1  2 แล้วก็กราบอย่างเงี้ย 1  2 กราบ
ออนักเรียนเรียว่าครูหญิงขำอะไรไม่ทำไม
ครูนิไม่นะไม่
นะผู้หญิงแค่คิดว่า
โอเคมันอยู่ใน
โบสถ์
เอ่อมันต้องเอาท่าไหนให้อันนี้ได้
มยเดี๋ยวคูณนิกลองหาดูว่าเจอรูปมยคูนิก
เจอมยคะคือผู้หญิงก็เจอแหละแต่ว่าไม่ใช่
เ่อมันก็ไม่ใช่รูปเด็ก
อ่ะคือครูนิกอ่ะครูนิกหาเป็นแบบนี้ที่อัน
นี้ครูนิกเจอแล้วครับมันจะเป็นแบบนี้คือ
ธีเออมันมีรูปอยู่มผู้หญิงก็เห็นแป๊บๆ
อยู่เมื่อกีนี้คือเนี่ยวิธีการไหว้พระ 1
2  3
4 แล้วเราก็จะเนี่ยนักเรียนแล้วเราก็จะ
ก้มแบบนี้อ่ะแล้วมันไม่ได้มีแค่นี้ไงข้าง
หลังเนี่ยก็มีคนใช่มั้ยคะมีเพื่อนครูนิก
เพื่อนครูนิกเพื่อนครูนิกแล้วก็นี่ก็คือ
หน้าของ
เค้า
ใช่แล้วมันเป็นยังไงต่อคะครูนิกก็ครูนิก
อ่ะก็มีเพื่อนก็อยู่กับเพื่อนในโบสถนี่
แหละก็พอตอนเบอร์ 4 เนี่ยแหละครับค่ะมัน
ก็
ปุ๋งเหมือนก็ที่นี่นะคะนักเรียนเวๆ
ๆก็เนี่ยแล้วเพื่อนเนี่ยก็อยู่ตรงเนี้ยต
เพื่อนก็แบบเพื่อนมันก็ตกใจเพื่อนบอกโอ๊
เฮ้ยนิก
ตดรู้แล้วว่าเป็นครูนิกใช่เพราะมันมัน
อยู่ข้างหลังครูนิกไงเพื่อนครูนิกอ่ะแล้ว
เค้า
ก็ได้ยินเสียง
แล้วคงคิดว่าเป็นลมอ่ะมันก็คงพัดมาอ
เ้ยแล้วมันไม่ได้มีแค่เพื่อนครูนิกมั้ย
อ่ะมันมีคนคนมีห้องอื่นๆที่อายุเท่ากัน
ด้วยใช่มั้ยคะใช่ก็ประมาณ 20  30
คนความรู้สึกตอนนั้นครูนิกคิดว่าครูนิก
อยากจะเอาอะไรมาคลุมหัวแล้วก็เดินออกไป
เลยมั้ยขายหน้ามากใชใช่ก็คนนี้ก็โอ๊ยแล้ว
เป็นวันแรกด้วยนะต้องอยู่ด้วยกันอีกทั้ง
หมด 3 วันเนี่ยอันนี้เพิ่งวันแรกน่ะตดใส่
หน้าเพื่อนไป
แล้วขายหน้ามยล่ะมากค่ะครูนี้เพื่อนๆทุก
คนก็แบบว่าเฮดูคววานเนี้ยกำลังกราบอยู่
อ่ะมันตบเวลาคุณนิเดินก็จะ
แบบอยากจะปิดหน้าเดินโอขายหน้ามากขายหน้า
มากแล้วคือใช่ว่าอยู่ที่วัดด้วยกัน 3 วัน
แต่พอกลับบ้านน่ะก็ต้องไปเจอเพื่อน
ที่ทำอยู่ที่วัดด้วยกันเนี่ยที่โรงเรียน
อยู่ดีเพราะเราอยู่ชั้งเดียวกันอยู่คนละ
ห้องแต่ว่าอยู่ม 5 เหมือนกันก็ต้องไปม 6
แล้วเพื่อนก็เรียกเหมือนกับมีชื่อเล่นว่า
นี่ไงนิกเนี่ยที่ตดใน
วัดถ้าสมมุติคุยกันว่าเออรู้จักนิกมั้ย
อ่ะอุยเค้าเนี่ยเค้าเรียนเก่งมากเลยนะ IQ
ดีเพื่อนก็จะบอกนิดไหนอ่ะนิกที่ตดในวัด
ไงใช่น่ะชื่อของครูนิกเหรอคะเออเป็นชื่อ
เล่นไปเลยคนี้บอกโอ๊ยขายหน้าขายหน้ามาก
มากๆค่ะครูนิกคือครูหิคิดว่านะครูนิกตอน
นั้นน่ะตอนที่ครูนิกตดออกไปไม่ว่าจะใน
ลิฟต์ที่อเมริกาหรือว่าในโบสถ์ที่ไทยนะคะ
หน้าครูนิกก็คงแบบ
ร้อนมากๆใช่มใช่ไงใช่ๆเออใช่เออแล้วก็ไม่
อยากเจอหน้าใครใช่มั้ยไม่อยากเห็นหน้าใคร
ไม่แบบตอนนั้นคืออายมากแล้วคือขายหน้ามาก
ใช่อ
เอ่าก็นั่นแหละครับเป็นเรื่องของครุนิ
แล้วูหญิงล่ะมีมั้ยเรื่องขายหน้าคือครู
หญิงอ่ะมีอยู่เรื่องนึงนะคะแบบว่าไม่ๆตด
นะคะนักเรียนไม่ตดนะแต่ว่า
เป็นอุ๊ยหยิบอะไรออกมาคือจำได้ว่า
อันเนี้ยก็รู้สึกแบบว่ามันก็ขายหน้าอยู่
นะรู้สึกแบบอยากจะไม่ไม่อยากให้ไม่อยาก
นั่งใกล้ๆเลยอ่ะค่ะคืออันนั้นน่ะเป็นเหตุ
การณ์ที่เกิดบนเครื่องบินครับเอนิดนึงนะ
คะแบบเครื่องบินใช่มั้ยคะอ่าเครื่องบิน
เนี่ยเราเนี่ยนั่งเครื่องบินคิดว่าตอน
นั้นจากญี่ปุ่นแล้วก็กลับกลับมาไทยกลับมา
ไทยแล้วก็อันนี้มันเป็นเก้าอี้ใช่ไหมมคะ
แบบ
คลาสอย่าเงี้ยมันน 2 คนมั้งถ้าูหญิงจำไม่
ผิดนะครับอืเพราะว่ามันจากญี่ปุ่นมันไฟ
สั้นใช่่ไหมยคะไลท์สั้นๆเนาะแล้วก็
เครื่องบินเนี่ยก็จะมีข้างหน้าของเราเนาะ
ข้างหน้าตรงเนี้ยอ่าเราก็ูหญิงอ่ะสมมุติ
ครูหญิงนั่งที่นี่แล้วก็ตรงนี้ก็จะเป็นจอ
ทีวีใช่มั้ยคะเป็นทีวีอ่าเครื่องบินเนี่ย
เขาก็จะแจกหูฟังครับหูฟังอ่าซึ่งูหญิงน่า
จะนั่งเครื่องบินเป็นแบบครั้ง
ที่ 4 มั้งครั้งที่ 3 ครั้งที่ 4 อ่ะเออ
แล้วแบบไม่เคยนั่งสายการบิน jpan  Air
ไม่แน่ใจนะคะจำสายการบินไม่ได้แต่เป็นของ
ญี่ปุ่นนั่นแหละค่ะแล้วก็ปกติอ่ะเวลาที่
เรานั่งเครื่องบินเนี่ยเรามีหูฟังใช่มั้ย
คะแล้วเขาจะเอาที่เนี่ยเสียบที่จออันนี้
คือที่ครูหญิงเคยเจอไงครับอ่ามันจะเสียบ
ที่จอตรงจอเนี่ยมันจะมีรูให้เราเสียบแล้ว
เราก็ใส่หูฟังแต่ว่าที่เนี่ยมันตรงนี้ก็
มีผู้ชาย 1 คนนะคะเป็น
ฝรั่งนั่งอยู่เป็นเด็กๆอ่ะค่ะวัยรุ่นอายุ
แบบ 20  21 อย่างเงี้ยค่ะแล้วครูหญิง
เนี่ยก็นั่งอยู่ตรงนี้แล้วผู้หญิงก็อยาก
ดูดูดูทีวีอ่ะเเรียกดูทีวีมั้ยดูหนัง
เอนเตอร์เทนเม้นอ่ะอ่าบนีเออบนเครื่องบิน
แล้วผู้หญิงก็มีหูฟังแล้วแล้วผู้หญิงก็
นั่งแบบหาแล้วก็เสียบอ่ะเสียบอยู่ตรงนั้น
น่ะประมาณ 3 นาที 4 นาทีอ่ะคแบบทำไมมัน
เสียบไม่เข้าทำไมมันเสียบไม่เข้าแล้วคน
ที่นั่งข้างๆเนี่ยเค้าก็คงดูว่าทำอะไรอื
ทำอะไรอยู่เค้าก็เลยบอกว่าเค้าก็สะกิดครู
หญิงอนะสะกิดแล้วก็บอกว่าเออที่เสียบ
เนี่ยอยู่ตรง
นี้อยู่ตรงที่แบบเวลาเรานั่งแล้วมันจะมี
ที่วางมืออ่ะที่วางแขนวางมือครับเออผู้
หญิง
ก็คนสแล้วคเสียบแล้วก็รู้สึกแบบไม่อยาก
นั่งตรงนี้เลยอีก 5 ชมงถึงจะถึงประเทศไทย
โอคือแบบเป็นความรู้สึกที่ขายหน้าคือคิด
อ่ะคิดว่าอันเนี้ยแหละเราก็ขายหน้าอยู่นะ
เพราะเรารู้สึกแบบหน้ามันร้อนเหมือนครู
นิกบอกอ่ะค่ะเออครับใช่ใช่เพราะว่าครูนิก
ก็คิดว่าก็มีเหมือนกันว่าคนที่นั่ง
เครื่องบินแล้วมันคือแต่ละสายการบินมันก็
มีอะไรที่ไม่เหมือนกันแล้วคนก็คนก็คิดว่า
เอ๊ะฉันมีเงินนั่งเครื่องบินนะจะมาขาย
หน้าเเนี่ยไม่ได้ใชคุณีมันเค้าก็จะรู้ว่า
อ๋อยายนี่ไม่เคยนั่งเครื่องบินหรือเปล่า
คันแรกแน่
ๆเราจะรู้สึกแบบไม่ได้นะเพราะนั่นแหละค่ะ
ก็เลยรู้สึกว่าเอออันเนี้ยเป็นเรื่องขาย
หน้าที่แบบเออจำได้แล้วรู้สึกว่าทุกวัน
นี้ก็ยังแบบเวลาฟังคิดถึงก็ยังรู้สึกแบบ
เออมันน่าขายหน้าจริงๆอ่ะเออคือแบบเสียบ
ไม่ได้ก็เสียบทำไมก็ไม่เข้าใจอ่ะค่ะเนาะ
ก็เลยมาเล่าให้ฟังนะคะเกี่ยวกับเรื่องขาย
หน้าของเรา 2 คนที่ทำให้เรารู้สึกแบบอยาก
จะเอาอะไรมาปิดหน้ามากๆนะคะแล้วนักเรียน
น่ะเคยมีเหมือนกันมั้ยอาจจะแบบบนเครื่อง
บินเหมือนครูหญิงหรือว่าเอิ่มแก๊สใน
ท้อง
ดมคุณนิกนักเรียนบอกไม่เล่าให้ฟังนะนัก
เรียนถ้าเล่าในอินเทอร์เน็ตก็ขายหน้ามาก
ขึ้นเลยตอนนี้ครูนิกไม่เป็นไรแล้วครูนิก
โตแล้วเนโตแล้วใช่ใช่ค่ะแต่ว่าคลิปนี้ก็
หมดเวลาแล้วเนาะงั้นเดี๋ยวเรามาเจอกัน
ใหม่ในวีีดีโอหน้านะคะใชครับไว้เจอกัน
ใหม่ใช่ค่ะสวัสดี
ค่ะ